ahora que ya vimos la interpolación
lineal veamos cómo podemos lograr un
movimiento más natural usando las curvas
de vez y la forma de cada parte en esta
curva de descontrolada por cuatro puntos
entonces cómo podemos escribir una
ecuación que nos dé una curva suave con
estos cuatro puntos
tal vez se acuerden de que nos
enfrentamos a un problema similar en la
lección de modelado ambiental ahí
tratamos de hacer hojas de pasto vimos
cómo usar tres puntos para definir un
arco parabólico usando el método de
esculturas con hilo
repasemos cómo funciona la construcción
de esculturas con hilo marquemos los
puntos como a b y c
también tenemos un parámetro llamado t
que nos dice qué tan lejos nos
encontramos sobre el segmento
primero podemos calcular un punto en ave
usando el promedio ponderado de estos
dos puntos
este es otro tipo de interpolación
lineal pero en lugar de usar la
pendiente ordenada al origen estamos
usando algo llamado forma paramétrica el
parámetro este y nos dice qué tan lejos
estamos en la línea
si te va de 0 a 1 a nuestro nuevo punto
vamos a llamarlo q va de ave
hagamos lo mismo pero en el otro
segmento calculando el punto r / b y c
finalmente usamos este mismo método
entre cullera para calcular p que es un
punto en la curva cómo te va de 0 a 1
entonces petras a una curva suave
pueden pensar en este método como una
interpolación lineal repetida donde q r
y p son calculados usando funciones
lineales de t
este método de interpolación es lineales
repetidas se conoce como algoritmo de
castelló nombrado así por paul de
castelló quien descubrió las matemáticas
de esto unos años antes que pierde 100
pero no se había publicado hasta que
decía publicó lo suyo ya vimos cómo el
algoritmo de castelló puede usarse para
generar una curva suave usando tres
puntos pero en animación queremos usar
cuatro puntos para controlar la curva
tomen un lápiz y papel y vean si pueden
resolver cómo lograr una curva suave
empezando con cuatro puntos en lugar de
tres